[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah when you dress like your hold on
a second whoa mr. t never make fun of
the way a man dresses wait a man dresses
is his business remember that whether
it's overalls chains or feather ear is
however they dress it's not to be joked
about
I pity the fool that judges another
man's clothing I'm sorry I judged your
clothing it's okay hey Scout there's a
man over there who said he'll give us
candy if we get in his van I don't know
if that's a good idea Timmy Oh what are
you afraid of is it because you have a
stupid name like Scout hey whoa mr. t
again never make fun of a person's name
your mama gave you that name oh you made
it up for business purposes all the
weight is personal I pity the fool to
make fun of another man's name mr. T's a
cool name it's a cool name mr. T
[Music]
hey scout why don't you some drugs
aren't drugs bad I don't know if you're
afraid of drugs we could drink a bunch
of alcohol YUM that sounds good well
guess what your hair is stupid never
make fun of another person's hair hey
mister a person's hair is the artwork
that they present to the heavens just
like
[Music]
[Music]
take
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
baldness you fools
[Music]
you